Ben Shapiro and Tucker Carlson okay I
want to read this and Rob if you can get
this clip prepared Ben Shapiro contemns
Tucker for downplaying Attack on Israel
its idiocy it's just moral stupidity Ben
Shapiro strongly condemns Saker Carlson
accusing a moral stupidity and criticize
them for downplaying the recent attack
shapir K Tucker Carlson comparing
between the Israel tragedy and drug
abuse deaths in United States declaring
he attempting he's attempting to
minimize as though America can't walk
and Shu come morally speaking at the
same time which is I'll just let you
watch this clip uh uh to judge it for
yourself go ahead
rob, a year now you can call it genocide
you can call it whatever you want but
it's the death of over a 100,000
Americans a year and the living death of
millions you can't call it genocide it's
not genocide so I don't understand
people who are addicted to drugs and
living outside Isel and again I I want
to add my voice to that cuz I'm a human
being but sure you do the the outrage
among Republican presidential candidates
was so much more intense one of them
took to a bull and started yelling about
it I get it but no one would think to do
that about the 100,000 American young
people murdered every year and because
who are you yelling at who are you
yelling at first of all people are on
borns yelling about drug overdoses and
the open border all the time all the
time what do he even talking about what
he's attempting to is minimize what
happened in Israel he's not attempting
to maximize what happened in the United
States he's attempting to minimize as
though America can't walk and gum
morally speaking at the same time which
is absurd and those two things are
nothing
I'm sorry that is not alike it is not
alike for drug smugglers to smuggle
drugs over the board which someone then
takes and shoves into their arm and then
they dive in overdose that is not the
same thing I promise you it is not the
same thing as a terrorist breaking into
your home and murdering your children in
their beds in front of you and dragging
your wife off to be raped in Gaza that
is not the same thing pretending that it
is is imoral it's a moral blight it's
idiocy it's just moral stupidity at the
highest level of course we should care
about what happens with fentanyl of
course we should care about we should
close our border have I been unclear
about this of course America should have
closed borders when it comes to this
sort of stuff I'm on the same side as
Tucker on that I just don't understand
why he's not on my side when it comes to
Hamas has to be wiped off the face of
the Earth pause it right there what
exactly is the counter aru Tom Adam go
ahead yeah well uh it's it's interesting
to see how this is playing out because
this is sort of a fissure of what's
going on in the in the Republican right
um in my opinion Ben Shapiro just
completely owned Tucker Carlson uh let
me unpack that a little bit so the the
trying to draw equivalency between what
Hamas is doing or what Isis did it
whether it becomes rapes mass murder
intentional genocide versus the active
decision to consume drugs over long
periods of time in some cases and then
di an overdose is
completely absolutely absurd the moral
equivalence knowing the risk of partying
when you did it correct so it and and
just like Ben said do we want to
fix our borders yes do we want to stop
fentol from pouring into our country yes
but at the end of the day people who are
using drugs very few people take it one
time and die very few it's over it's a
it's a long slow process so the decision
to actively take drugs heroin pills
cocaine whatever the drug is and use it
and use it and use it and use it and
eventually die okay you're making this
active decision nobody made an active
decision in Israel will be sitting in
your homes at at 6:00 in the morning
Hamas bust in your door and shoots you
and your babies in the head that is a
totally different situation so in my
opinion Ben Shiro is spot on on this one
and Tucker is just blatantly wrong Tom
uh I have my thoughts I want to hear
your thoughts well I I agree you know
Tucker did not sound outraged and it
sounded like he was balancing the
argument um and then Ben gets pretty
revved up uh Ben's a hawk and he gets
pretty revved up and I think he is
correct that you can't draw moral
equivalency with a decisionist thing
because you happen to be Jewish and
you're attacked and a decision to be on
college campus aren't you worried about
fentanyl yeah I'm worried about fentanyl
just get one of those fentanyl test kits
you can get those test kits and you can
rub the rub the pill on it see if
there's any fentanyl in there but yeah
there's a big difference between the two
of those and I think Tucker was was you
know could have done a better job and
left the door open to kind of be owned
by Shapiro here's what I would say
number one um I think I totally
understand Tucker and I totally
understand Ben okay number one Tucker
what's Tucker's number one loyalty and
Affinity America America First what are
we talking America First he's going to
sit there and say yeah to that's your
problem first of all this Sunday we with
the family and for whatever reason tikon
Dylan wanted to watch Zohan okay I don't
know if you guys know Zohan with Adam
Sandler whatever the movie what's the
movie called The Legend Of
Z by the way you know the whole story is
about how he's a IDF killer sold comes
to us wants to work for Paul Mitchell
cutting here and he goes and finally
becomes this hair stylist at this salon
and the owner of the salon is gorgeous
girl who's a Palestinian and they fall
in love and they're trying to bring
peace between Palestine and Israel what
a weird movie to watch at a time like
this Jen and I are looking at each other
laughing but at the same time saying
everything he's talking about they're
talking about right now applies to
current times okay Ben Tucker's priority
is America First of course he's going to
be about America he's sitting there
saying dude these guys have been
fighting for 2,000 years you think I can
stop it yeah you guys been fighting for
thousands of years one day America's
going to wake up and stop you guys from
fighting it's a joke if we think this
fight's going to end up anytime soon
that's how I think that Tucker sees it
but I also see Ben guess where Ben is
from there that's his family that's
where he's from of course he's going to
be protective
of his homeland his pride you know he
you know the voice he has for the Jewish
Community 100% he's going to see that
from an emotional connection to it one
has to sit there and entertain both
ideas is all I'm saying both could be
right and both could be emotionally
leaning towards whatever is protective
of theirs yeah Tucker is going to
protect America and Ben is going to
protect Israel and a way that hey we got
to make sure this is number one priority
to Tucker no one in the world has been
able to prevent this fight from
happening for 2,000 years including God
you think you can do it yeah Let Them
Fight they're going to keep fighting
okay let them fight they're going to go
back and forth so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here